[Music]
gravity falls is one of the best
cartoons out there and we're still sad
it's actually over if you're a true fan
of the show stick to the end the
ultimate gravity falls Easter eggs if
you're new here hit that subscribe
button to never miss another video and
don't forget to give us a big thumbs up
let's check out 10 pop culture
connections in gravity falls that will
make your jaw drop
just Spice Girls yes you heard it right
gravity falls has the Spice Girls
reference and we're pretty sure you
never even noticed it because of
everything else that happens in this
episode in carpet DM the 16th episode of
season 1 we see how hard it sometimes is
to share a room with a sibling after
dipper complains Suze finds a room in
the shack this turns everything into a
competition as dipper and Mabel compete
for the room unaware that the rooms
carpet comes with some magical powers
but before we get to that let's rewind
to the scene where the girls have their
sleepover party during the aftermath and
right before Mabel reveals the party
girl riding on her forehead you can see
a DVD on her face the title of the DVD
is boy's world which is a reference to
the Spice Girls movie called spice world
if you look at the boy characters you'll
notice they're in the exact same
position as the Spice Girls on their DVD
cover it only makes sense to give a
tribute to the Spice Girls during a
sleepover right and it looks like the
girls definitely did spice up their
lives during that sleepover too poor
dipper we totally understand why he
wasn't able to stay in that room for
much longer
Steven universe Steven universe is
definitely one of the weirdest cartoons
ever so it's no wonder it got a shout
out in gravity falls this Easter egg was
so cleverly designed - bet you never
even noticed it in the first place and
to be honest it took us a couple of
seconds before we realized what we were
actually looking at a tale of two Stan's
is pretty creepy on its own but what
makes it even better is this Easter Egg
we loved Steven universe and apparently
so does gravity falls you can see Ford
stand in front of a chalkboard hiding a
mysterious figure but shift your eyes to
the left
to see the Steven universe reference
it's the diamond authority symbol but of
course just like with other connections
we will mention gravity falls had a
slightly mass miss Easter egg and
rearrange the colors it also doubles as
the actual symbol of hazardous chemicals
the red color on the symbol represents
the fire hazard the blue is a health
hazard
yellow is reactivity and white symbol a
specific hazard which only makes us
wonder why it was symbol so similar in
the first place but we still think this
is a creatively hidden shout-out to
Steven universe and the slightly bizarre
gym leaders what do you think let's
debate in the comments Lady and the
[ __ ] since gravity falls is a Disney
cartoon it only makes sense to give a
shout-out to other iconic Disney movies
but you won't see glass slippers or
Birds braiding someone's hair in this
show you'll see Mabel eating a pizza
with the pig she won at Stan's mystery
fair but the way they're eating the
pizza is very similar to the iconic
scene from The Lady and the [ __ ] sure
this type of scene would only make sense
to the show like gravity falls but hey
let's pretend that tearing pizza with a
pig is totally normal and just as
romantic as eating spaghetti and lady in
the [ __ ]
Mabel's love for that pig is completely
adorable even though we cringe which she
was also given a fork in a knife when
she won the pig the entire episode
focuses on of course dippers love for
Wendy and him desperately trying to make
things right after he accidentally hits
Wendy in her eye with a ball and let's
face it her love for that pig made this
episode even more wonderful even though
some parts were definitely weird
let's just hope there wasn't any bacon
on that pizza although considering this
is gravity falls there's a good chance
there was the Muppets
gravity falls is known to draw
inspiration from pretty much anywhere
and in this particular episode they paid
homage to one of the most beloved
old-school shows ever it's time to play
music it's time to light the lights soft
opera the fourth episode of season two
is all about Mabel putting on a sock
puppet rock opera to impress a local
puppeteer welcome Mabel can come up with
something as creative as a sock puppet
rock opera
of course she makes dipper join in on
the fun too but make sure you watch the
credits where you can see Mabel's sock
puppet crack a joke we see old man
mcgucket and grunkle Stan watching the
show from the audience Oh BAM mcgucket
says that the puppet show was really
something and grunkle Stan adds it was
something terrible the two laugh the
bath not all that's funny about that
team the way these two are set up
reminds us of Statler and Waldorf from
the Muppet Show these two always love to
hate on the show they watch and heckle
the entire cast they're easily known as
the show's greatest critics which is
exactly what gravity falls tried to
portray mcgucket and Stan scene is
exactly the same as Statler and Waldorf
to be fair we're pretty sure that these
two would make just as awesome critics
as Statler and Waldorf the Little Shop
of Horrors in the sixth episode of the
second season were introduced to another
side of mystery shack of course mystery
shack holds so much more mysteries than
we could ever know about sand explains
that the mystery shacks spookiest
attractions go on sale after hours those
attractions are things normal people
would probably find just a little bit if
not a lot creepy it's definitely not an
easy episode to watch especially not
after what the witches do to Stan but
pay attention to the actual title of the
episode it's called the little gift Shop
of Horrors which is a direct reference
to the 1960s movie called The Little
Shop of Horrors this dark comedy was so
popular it actually got a Broadway
revival in 2003 although gravity falls
version is much more creepy the Little
Shop of Horrors definitely has scenes
that will make you never get close to
another planet again saying grunkle Stan
without hands definitely gave us
nightmares but anyways it was nice to
see gravity falls give a little tribute
to an iconic yet slightly creepy movie
about the secret life of plants but even
though it comes with an interesting
episode this
episode is definitely not the one to
watch if you're the type that gets
easily scared by seeing a character
without certain body parts Tron fighting
fighters is the perfect episode for
everyone that loves to play games in the
beginning of the episode soos shows Stan
and Mabel the arcade games while dipper
of course plays a game with Wendy there
are so many game titles in this scene
it's no wonder we could find some of
them also related to pop-culture
references this one is pretty cleverly
hidden and it probably won't make sense
unless you saw Tron the movie in one of
the scenes we see suits playing the game
he later crawls into a video game after
wanting to know what it would be like to
be inside the game for real he later
gets trapped in the game which is pretty
creepy but pay attention to the actual
name of the game the title says north
which is Tron spelled backwards but
what's even better is the obvious
tagline underneath saying that it's the
game based on the movie based on the
game it's a shout out to trial the movie
which has the same concept of a
character literally getting in the
gaming world we can now see where
gravity falls got the inspiration for
this episode so it's only appropriate to
credit the plot of the movie in some way
besides Tron sounds way better than Nord
anyways don't stop believing
we apologize in advance but you're about
to get don't stop believing sung by
journeys stuck in your head all day long
gravity falls likes to make pop-culture
connections in their own unique way of
course they can't just show the exact
reference they have to cleverly mask it
this also makes it much cooler when you
finally realize what they meant all this
time in the seventh episode of season 1
Mabel competes with Pacifica for the
title of the party Queen during mystery
shacks weekend party it's safe to say
that the title belongs to Mabel
regardless of this competition because
no one knows how to party as crazy as
Mabel does she starts singing karaoke to
the most 80s as crowd-pleasing his rock
ballad iasts song ever those were her
choice of words not ours the tune of
don't stop believing comes on but of
course gravity falls how to get creative
with it and change it she don't start
unbelieving which basically means the
same thing
Mabel sings don't start on believin
never do not feel you're feeling which
has the same meaning as don't stop
believin Korres now let's stick it all
together just a small-town girl
the lowly world but really we're sorry
you'll have the song stuck in your head
for the rest of the day though moonwalk
the mystery shack party episode doesn't
only highlight the reference to one of
the best 80s songs ever it also
references one of the best 80s
performers ever you probably noticed
this one because let's be honest now I
never expected this from a gravity falls
character the episode is all about
partying until you drop and the
characters definitely did just that
of course dipper and Wendy have their
own little love story going on or at
least they try to but focus on one of
the moments right before Wendy shows
dipper her family picture we can see
people having fun on the dance floor
when a tall guy decides to moonwalk
across the floor he does so by tricking
people into thinking he's moving forward
when he's actually smoothly gliding back
the move was practically invented by the
one and only Michael Jackson who could
do the moonwalk but no one else he's
still known as one of the greatest
performers of all time and his work will
never be forgotten how could I be when
even a cartoon like gravity falls had to
give it a shout-out to the best of the
best in the music industry speaking of
the fast is the best if you like horror
games stay tuned for the next pop
culture connection and make sure you
check out our very last one chucky
cheese this one is a little bit spooky
because the timing of it really doesn't
make sense you'll see what we mean in
just a few seconds in the fifth episode
of season 2 soos really needs a date for
his cousin's engagement party
so he tries it out with a dating
simulator game so that he can practice
talking to girls meanwhile Stan tries to
find a replacement for Goldie and is
talked into attending a Jamboree that's
clearly meant for kids but pay attention
to some of the characters you see at the
Jamboree from the ones at the arcade to
the band on stage these characters have
something in common they look very much
like the characters from Chuckie Cheese
but what's even scarier is that they're
even more similar to the characters from
the horror game called five nights at
Freddy's of course the game was inspired
by Chuckie Cheese but what's crazy is
that this particular episode aired only
one month after
five nights at freddys was released is
it a coincidence or just a reference to
Chuckie Cheese needless to say whether
he's talking about the game or the
concert grunkle Stan is right as we also
don't have any idea why kids would like
this sort of stuff in the first place
gravity falls but what gravity falls
does best is putting Easter eggs of its
own show in some of the episodes these
are the cartoon characters you don't pay
much attention to and storylines that
get forgotten the minute the episode is
over
for example after appearing in season
two agent powers and agent trigger can
actually be seen in the background of
more than just one episode you can even
spot them in the audience of this
episode where Mabel puts on the sock
puppet show they're the ones hiding
their faces and reading a magazine
they also very briefly and mysteriously
appear in season 2 episode 9 when the
camera shows the festival goers having
fun they're always watching another
character that frequently makes an
appearance is the time traveler whose
name is blendin blandin you can see him
picking something up on the beach is a
legend of gobblewonker and he can be
found in the back audience of the
headhunters episode his identity is
finally revealed in The Time Traveller's
page but many didn't even notice he was
there before him there are very few
other shows that are able to take
popular sized characters and make them
appear in several other episodes without
many people even noticing after all the
time traveler and both agents are
definitely a part of gravity falls pop
culture that's it for our video don't
forget to subscribe to our channel and
hit that like button for more videos
like this one see you next time
[Music]